Okay. So, um let us review last class.
So, last class we discussed the British
Empire and how it ultimately triumphed
over its main rivals who were the
French, the Spanish and the Dutch
because of three major
uh powers. Okay. The first is the Bank
of England.
What made the Bank of England
so important is that it could absorb
foreign capital,
okay, from all around the world. So at
first it absorbed capital from the Dutch
Republic, but then if you uh were a
French aristocrat, if you were the
Catholic Church, if you're the
Habsburgs, you could all move your
capital to England where it would be
safe because it' be be protected by the
law. Okay, that your property rights. Um
and when Britain became an empire, this
was important because uh local elites in
China, in India, in Southeast Asia would
help the British because they were
incentivized to do so. They could help
the British steal from these places and
then move capital, their wealth to
England or uh one of the British
colonies for safekeeping. Okay, so
that's a source of English power. Second
is the idea of soft power right so we
are in school learning English because
we want to go and study in the west
that's soft power right so Shakespeare
the BBC
um Oxbridge are all components of
British soft power which still rules the
world today and the third of course is
the British navy which controls seal
lanes and therefore controls all trade.
Okay. So for the longest time for 100
100 years Britain was able to maintain a
global empire
which really was the first global empire
because it spanned the entire world.
But there were three problems or three
limitations
to the British Empire. Okay. So the
first major limitation
limitations
the first major limitation is that
Britain
had an ethnicity. It had a race. It was
the white people, the Anglo-Saxons.
And so even though Britain was ruling
over Vasco Empire, it was very much
racist. It saw itself as superior to
everyone else and that limited its
capacity to work with local elites.
Okay. So in other words, eventually
India rebelled to establish its
independence and eventually Britain lost
its over overseas empire. A classic
[snorts] example of course is 2016
Brexit when the English people decided
that we we no longer wanted to be part
of Europe. Okay? And so even though
Britain is an empire, its people are
very provincial. Okay? They see
themselves as better and they they see
themselves as separate from everyone
else. I've met English people who've
told me like English people cannot learn
a foreign language. English speak people
speak English very well and that's it.
They can't learn French, they can't
learn Spanish, they refuse to learn
Chinese. And they told me it's because
their brains are different. Okay, their
brains are hardwired to speak English
really well and that's it. All right, so
that's just the British attitude. Um,
second problem is the idea of currency
um or wealth
standard.
The idea here is that okay, yes, you're
uh you're stealing wealth from other
places, but what is wealth? Okay. And
for the longest time, people understood
wealth as gold. The problem with this is
that there's a limitation or there's a
limit the amount of gold in the world
and therefore there's a limit to how
many people can participate in this game
and how much money they can win in the
end. Okay? So, it's really a game only
for the elite. That's the second major
limitation.
Okay. And the third problem for Britain
is that it's really a small island
with very few people and very limited
resources and therefore it was really
not sustainable for Britain to control
the entire world. there's a limitation
to its reach and ultimately other powers
in Europe would arise to challenge uh
British hegemony including Russia
including Germany. [snorts] Ultimately
the power that would overthrow the
British Empire to create its own empire
is of course America and what America
would do that's very important is
resolve all three of these limitations
to to create a world game in which we
all play today. Okay, so Britain um
basically
birthe this game, but there were
limitations to how far this game could
spread. America will then take the
concept of this game and spread it all
around the world until it conquered the
entire world. Okay, so how did they do
so? All right, so let's go over America.
Well, first of all, America is not a
small island. It is a continental
fortress. And in fact, it controls the
entire western western hemisphere. We
know that the western hemisphere is very
very wealthy. Okay. So America h is not
just the country of America. It's really
the western hemisphere
[clears throat] and as such has
unlimited population and it's unlimited
resources has unlimited land. Okay. So
this resolves the issue of um resources.
Okay. Second problem the currency. Well,
what America would do [clears throat]
that would revolutionize the world is
make the US dollar the standard of
wealth in the world. And because the US
dollar is just a concept, it's just an
idea.
Everyone can now play this game and
wealth can now be infinite. Okay,
but that makes sense, right? Before gold
was what everyone was playing for, but
there's a limit to gold. But with US
dollars, anyone and everyone in the
world can now play. Okay. So I'll talk
about how the US dollar became uh the
center of wealth in the world. Now the
ethnicity is another problem. Okay. And
so what America did that was very clever
is tell the world we are not an
ethnicity. Okay? We're not a land. What
we really are is a game. All right. So
the idea is that America became a nation
game.
All right. So um what so this is pretty
easy to understand. Okay. So I'm going
to explain this first and then I'm I'm
going to explain how the dollar came to
dominate the world. Okay. All right.
[snorts] All right. So for the longest
time
we had problems deciding what a game or
a nation ought to be. Okay. So um
traditionally nations have been ruled uh
politically through the monarchy. Okay.
um an oligarchy,
a democracy
or a theocracy. Okay, so there are
others but these are the four major
ones. A monarchy is very simple. A king
is in charge. Everyone just obeys the
king. Uh oligarchy is where the nobility
are in charge. Another name for
oligarchy is the aristocracy. Okay? And
that's basically Rome.
A democracy is where the people make all
the decisions. And so what happens is
that if a decision is to be made, people
get together and they give speeches.
Whoever gives the best speech gets the
most votes and then that decision is
implemented. Okay? And of course the
classic example of democracy is Athens.
[snorts]
Okay? And then you have a theocracy
which is to say that the priests are in
charge and the priests represent the
will of God. Okay. And of course uh
theocracy the last example is a Catholic
Europe. This is a medieval Europe when
the Catholic Church was in charge. All
right. But starting with the
enlightenment
uh when God was no longer considered
that important philosophers debated
amongst themselves what a nation ought
to be what society ought to be. Okay.
And so let's discuss the major theories
of this time period. All right. So the
first idea is
[snorts and clears throat] if God
doesn't really matter. Okay. If it's up
to humans to decide how to structure
societies, how can you best do so? And
at this time, the most popular idea is
social contract theory, social contract
theory.
And there are two major theorists. Okay.
The first is John Lock who of course is
English.
And for him,
government it's very simple. Okay. Human
beings have three fundamental rights
that God gave us. Okay. Which are inel
inelable which means that no one can
take take away from us. The first is
life. Okay. The second is liberty. The
right to say whatever we want. The right
to do whatever we want. The third is the
pursuit of property wealth. Okay. So
they have private property. In other
words, [clears throat]
government exists in order to pro
protect the wealth that we generate for
our hard work. And if we steal it,
that's okay as well. Okay. If we kill
out people uh in India, China, and
France to get it, that's okay, too,
because it happened elsewhere. Okay. All
right. So, private property. And as you
can imagine, um if you have wealth, you
like the system a lot. And not only
that, but you are encouraged, you're
incentivized to work really hard. And
that's what actually allowed uh England
to overtake um the French, the Dutch,
and the Spanish. Okay. Then you have
another theorist named John Rouso.
And this theory is different. Okay. It's
also social contract theory, but it's a
different idea, which is okay, we're
born in a state of nature. We have
complete freedom. We can do whatever we
want.
So why do we choose to give up this
freedom and come into society? Okay, the
reason why is when we do so we create a
social social contract that creates the
general will.
Okay? And the general will is a
substitute for God. It is the expression
of the best of who we are. Okay? Do you
understand? So by ourselves we're fine.
Okay? When we come together, we create a
new concept that allows us to be truly
and fully human. The general will. So
what is general will? Okay. All right.
So uh think of Emilion Kant
[clears throat]
was a German philosopher and he
explained that the very basis of
humanity
what we should all try to achieve is
something called the categorical
imperative.
Okay, the categorical imperative is the
highest moral law, right? It's really
God's law. And there are three
components to the categorical
imperative. Okay, the first is the idea
of universality. [clears throat]
Universality just means that imagine
this. Whatever you do, everyone else
around you will automatically do. Okay?
So, if you want to go drink alcohol,
everyone's going to drink alcohol. Do
you want to live in a study of
alcoholics? Okay. If you cheat on a
test, everyone immediately is going to
cheat as well. Do you want to live
inside of cheaters?
Okay. If you read books, everyone else
is going to read books. So, imagine that
whatever you do will be replicated by
everyone else immediately. Okay? That's
the idea of universality. Second is the
idea of free will.
Okay, I know that eating ice cream is
bad. I know that uh eating protein,
chicken is good. Okay, but I cannot be
forced to eat chicken even though it's
better for me. I have to choose to eat
chicken by myself. If I want to eat ice
cream, I can do that. Okay. So we cannot
coersse people to do what they do not
want to do.
All right.
And number three is
uh human
um is the end onto itself. Okay. And the
idea here is that you cannot
use humans a human being to achieve a
higher purpose because humans are the
ultimate purpose. So I can't be like a
king that says you know what I'm going
to war to make a lot of money for
everyone and I'll sacrifice 50% of my
people but the other 50% who live will
be happy. They'll live in paradise. You
can't do that. Okay. Because you cannot
sacrifice anyone's life in order to
achieve a higher end because the
ultimate end is the human life. Okay. So
that's the idea of the categorical
imperative. And this becomes the
theoretical basis for the general will.
Okay. Now in practical terms, how do you
implement this in society? Well, the
general will gives rise to government
and then the government gives rise to
laws.
Okay? So the legitimacy of the
government comes from the consensus of
the people which is the general will.
The general will is not democracy,
right? The general will is an abstract
idea which represents the best of who we
can be.
All right. So just because everyone's
like, "Okay, we should all vote to kill
that person because we don't like him."
No, that's not the general will. The
general will is everyone is important.
Do unto others as you would want others
to do unto you. Okay? So you can't kill
anyone. Okay? And if you if people vote
for this, then government is
illegitimate because it goes against the
general will. All right? And this is
important for us because this becomes
the basis of the French Revolution.
And the French Revolution,
the entire European [clears throat]
continent, okay, including Britain,
Prussia, Austria, Russia, everyone got
together and attacked France. France was
poor. France had no monarchy. But France
defeated everyone.
Why? Because people were energized to
fight for their nation. They believe
that I am now part of a greater good of
equity in this game. Therefore, I will
defend this nation with my life. And
France for the longest time was
unbeatable on the battlefield. Okay.
All right. So that is the French
conception of a nation. A nation is a
social contract which guarantees rights
to its citizens and in return its
citizens must be willing to sacrifice
its life for the nation and that's why
um the French revolution was so
successful which ultimately led to the
French empire under Napoleon. Okay, does
that make sense? Now there's another
conception of the nation state which is
this.
Okay, and these are the Prussians or the
Germans. Okay. And it's idea of um iron
and blood.
So a nation is not something that you
choose to get into. Okay? It's not
something that you sign in contact with.
A nation is in your blood. A nation is
language,
heritage,
land. Okay?
and you prove that you are worthy by
sacrifice your sacrificing yourself in
battle. Okay, this is this comes to us
from the German in 1870.
Okay, in the FrancoRussian war between
Prussia and France, these two concepts
of the nation state came into battle.
Okay, the French was a social contract.
You fight for us because you agree to be
a citizen of this nation which
guarantees you certain rights. Prussia
is like no you fight because it is your
duty to fight because it is in your
blood it is in your language it is in
your culture it's in your family and
then when these two cultures clash it
was the Prussians who won and
um that created of course Germany okay
so in 1870 the current the modern nation
of Germany was founded by the Persians
when it defeated France in the Franco
Pussian war right so Now we go to
America.
Okay. And America
has a different conception
of the nation state. Okay. So at this
time in history first of all
um America it's a very small place 13
colonies and the continent is controlled
by these indigenous people. The French
are there the Spanish are there. Okay.
And but the Americans are very very
ambitious and they are expanding really
really fast and Britain the home country
actually becomes
um afraid of America because at this
time about the 1700s America has more
people. It's wealthier. It's welcoming
people from all around Europe. And so
Britain tries to limit the expansion of
America. Okay? It tries to say you can't
cross the certain line, the Appalachian
Mountains. America says screw you. We're
going to revolt. Okay, this creates the
American Revolution.
And in 1789,
um, America creates the Constitution,
which becomes the highest law in the
land. And so at this point in history,
America, the American founding fathers,
they look around the world, they know
about the British system, they know
about the French system. Um, they're
trying to grow the country as fast as
possible. They're they have to fight the
Spanish, the French, the British, and
the indigenous people in their land.
They're trying to welcome as many people
as possible. Okay? So they decide that
the nation will become a game. Okay? a
game
where the citizen is a player and the
citizen is trying to maximize his
wealth. Okay? And through this process
of maximizing his wealth, trying to get
as much wealth as possible, he will be
energetic. He will work hard and this
energy will contribute to the overall
wealth of the nation which will allow
America to grow very very fast. Okay,
that's a plan. All right, so for this to
work, they have to control the game that
has three major characteristics. All
right, the first is that it has to be
open,
meaning anyone can come and play. Okay,
but that just means also limiting the
history and the ethnicity of the uh
place. Okay. So the concept that America
creates is the idea of melting pot.
We welcome anyone who comes to America
regardless of your race, regardless of
your history, regardless of your wealth,
as long as you're willing to assimilate
into America into the melting pot. Okay,
that's the first idea. Second idea is
fairness.
And the third is clarity.
So, in other words, people are willing
to play a game and work really hard to
win this game if first of all they can
play this game. They're allowed to play
this game. They're not discriminated
against.
Um, also if the rules are really clear,
okay, you understand what the rules are.
In America, the rules are very simple.
You go to America, you follow the law,
you work really hard, you get rich,
okay, really simple. It's called the
American dream, right?
Um
and the third thing of course is that
the game is fair. Meaning the only
criterion
to generate wealth is how hard you work,
how much talent you have, how much merit
you have, right? The idea of merit.
Okay? And look, this is true. When you
go to America, you will discover this.
If you work really hard, if you're
really talented, if you're really smart,
they will respect that. Okay? I've been
to a lot of countries and I can tell you
that America in America this is true but
it's not true in Canada. I grew up in
Canada and they don't really care if
you're ambitious don't care if you're
smart don't care if you work hard. They
don't care. They expect you to follow
the rules and conform. Okay, that's
Canada. You go China. Okay, we all know
what China is. Okay, no one cares if you
work hard. No one cares if you're smart.
No one cares. Okay, it's all about your
guanchi about where your family. Okay.
But it's true for actually this is true
for most of the world. And I would say
that the idea of merit is only true for
two places. America is the most obvious
example. Okay. I've been to meetings
where at first Americans are like this
guy is Chinese. He probably doesn't
speak any English. He's not that smart.
Okay. So there's discrim discrimination
going on. But the moment I speak, the
moment I try to make my case, they are
win over won over by my logic. Okay. by
my arguments, by my creativity, and they
welcome me into the club. That's just
the American attitude of being
open-minded, of being generous, of
appreciating your talent above everyone
else. Okay. The British are the English
are also very similar in that way in
that, yeah, maybe they're racist, but if
you can make a good argument in front of
them, they will accept your argument.
Okay? But guess what, guys? Nowhere else
is this true. Okay? In China, China, you
have the best argument in the world. No
one cares, right? Okay. So, we there are
lots of issues with America, but in all
honesty, America is a place that really
does appreciate merit and which really
does reward merit. That's why everyone
wants to go go to America. All right.
All right. So, the question then is how
did America create the system? Okay.
Well, it did so through the
constitution.
The idea of the constitution is to
create a game and make this game above
power. Okay? And how they did that is
creating a system of government that
checks and balances each other. So you
have the president,
you have the congress, okay?
And you have the Supreme Court.
Okay. The Supreme Court it's very
simple. It's to interpret the
constitution
which the highest law in the land. Okay.
And then the powers of the government
are divided equally amongst these
different branches. So the Congress can
create laws and control spending. Okay.
what's called the purse.
The president has war powers basically
or the sword.
Okay. But if the president were to
declare war, he needs congress to
approve because congress has to give the
money to start the war. Okay. And um the
idea that the constitution is the
highest law in the land means that it's
really rule of law.
Okay. So even though you have this
government system in place, you also
have another parallel system called the
judiciary, the court system which
protects property rights in the same way
that they do in um Britain. Okay, does
that make sense? So so the very idea is
that this is a game. The government is a
system to maintain the openness, clarity
and fairness of the game. And because of
this, America was very quickly
able to dominate the world. Okay. The
thing about this game, okay, that's very
important for us to understand is it is
expansionist.
Okay. [snorts]
So what happened is that in its history,
America faced certain challenges to this
game and this game won out every single
time. Okay. So the first major challenge
to this game is called the American
Civil War.
All right. So let me explain what
happened.
From 1861 to 1864, the Civil War was
fought between the North and the South.
This was a clash of e economic systems.
Okay? So the north played the game.
Okay? And so it believed in free labor.
The South was its own independent
economic system that focused on
agriculture. And so it used slave labor.
For many Americans in the north, slave
labor was offensive because it corrupted
the game. Okay? Because remember,
America started on the idea of openness,
fairness, and clarity. But if you're a
slave, that's not fair, okay? Because
you were born a slave and you can never
participate in this game. And so they
fought a civil war to decide which who
will trumpet in the end. And of course
the north won because the north focused
on free labor. So that meant that there
were more people in the north. That
meant that the north was wealthier
because of manufacturing and that meant
that the north were more energetic.
Okay? So they defeated the south. And so
that was the first major challenge.
Now the game is spreading. Okay, it
spreads across America and now it stops
because America can't expand anymore.
Okay, it basically conquers the west
and be and now the game is an issue
because of the nature of money. The
problem with money is that
ultimately the the longer you play this
game
at the end of the game one person
controls all the money. Okay, does that
make sense? That's a problem of
capitalism. That's a problem with this
game. So now now that the frontier has
been settled, now that the borders have
been controlled, a few people are now
controlling all the money which leads to
the great depression. Okay. So now the
solution is America has to go and
conquer the world which it does. Okay.
In World War II, America conquers the
world. And so now what America needs to
do is spread this game throughout the
world. And it does that by creating the
US dollar. Okay. So 1945 America wins
the war. A year before in July July 1944
for one month what happens is that
America organizes something called a
bread and woods conference.
in New Hampshire. Okay. And the idea of
the bread and woods conference is to
establish
the world game. Okay. Before America's
game was limited to America, but now
America wants to scale its game to the
entire world. Okay. So, how does it do
that? Well, first thing it does is
it makes the US dollar
the reserve currency of the world.
All right. What does that mean? It means
that every other currency has to be
derived from the US dollar. Every other
currency will find value from the US
dollar. Okay? which means that if you
have Canadian dollars, you can now um
change it for US dollars, which is
what's valuable. The Canadian dollars is
just not valuable. Okay? All right. They
also agree on um exchange rate.
Okay?
It doesn't make sense. Okay? And this
this is a system that we have today.
Okay? All right. The global reserve
currency is the US dollar. That's what's
valuable. The ring B deres value from
its relationship with the US dollar. The
room is not valued by by itself. Okay.
All right. That's number one.
Um, okay. So now you're like, wait a
minute here.
If this is true, the US dollar can the
Americans can just put as much money as
they want. And so to solve this problem,
uh, the Americans said
the US dollar
will be pegged to gold.
Okay.
doesn't make sense. Okay? Meaning like
you can always take your dollar and
change exchange it for gold. And because
there's a limit [clears throat] to gold,
there has to be a limit to the US
dollars which keeps the system stable.
Okay? All right. That's number one.
Number two is
America needs to expand this game. Okay?
Because it is in competition with the
Soviet Union which is against this game.
Okay? So it creates two new
organizations to spread the game
throughout the world. And these two game
and these two organizations are called
the World Bank and the International
Monetary Fund, the IMF, IMF. Okay? So
um I'm so for the sake of simplicity.
Okay, understand this.
The World Bank, their job is to give you
loans. Okay? So let's say you are China
and you are poor, right? And you need to
build dams. Well, the World Bank gives
you money. And when he gives you money,
what it does is it allows you to start
playing this game. Okay? It allows you
to participate in this game. Now, what
always happens is
um eventually the countries pour so much
money they have to go into debt and they
can't pay off the money, right? So then
what happens is the IMF comes in and
changes your government and it policies
to make it conform more to the game.
Okay? Does that make sense? And its main
mechanism is called privatization.
All right? So, what the IMF says is,
okay, well, you're inefficient. You
can't pay off the debt because you're
inefficient. You're inefficient because
the public should not be control of
infrastructure. The public should not be
control of water. Okay? Private
companies should be in charge of the
water and electricity and the land.
Okay? So, uh the the goal of the World
Bank MF is to spread the game throughout
the world. All right. Okay. Then in um
they create create something called the
GAT. Okay. The GAT is a general
agreement on tariff and trade. So this
is the WTO basically. Okay. That changes
into the WTO
in 1995.
All right. So [clears throat] it's
basically agreement on free trade.
Right? Does that make sense? 1973
um Swift
is an agreement um amongst different
banks in the world on how to transfer
money. Okay. So for example, if you want
to transfer money from China B into
America to go to university, right?
Guess what guys? It has let's go for
Swift. Okay. So now it allow allows for
more cooperation among banks in the
world to use US dollars.
All right. Um now the last thing is okay
how do these countries get together and
decide on how to cooperate economically?
And the answer is the bank of
international settlements. Okay.
Okay. And this is the idea is that the
central banks of different countries get
together and they agree on certain
policies. All right. And this is all
done privately in secret. No one knows
about them. Okay. All right. So this is
the game that America uh creates. It's
very simple. Okay. Um and there are
other components but but we'll focus on
this now throughout the semester we will
focus more we will focus on how this
game is played specifically but first I
just introduce it to you. All right.
Okay. So now let's talk about how the
dollar conquers the world.
All right.
So for the longest time
um this system works well. Okay. The
United States is in competition with the
Soviet Union. But over time, the
Americans start to abuse this system. So
they pay for things they can't really
pay for. For example, the war in
Vietnam, for example, a space race, for
example, something called the Great
Society. Okay? They're just spending too
much money. And other countries start to
freak out. So France basically withdraws
all all its gold from the United States.
So, in 1971,
what Nixon does is say, "You know what?
Um, here's the secret, guys. We actually
don't have have enough gold to pay off
everyone." Okay? So, screw this. We're
not going to peg the gold uh the dollar
to gold anymore. Okay? Do you
understand? You can now you can no
longer redeem your US dollars for gold.
It's done. Okay? So now what happens is
the US dollar becomes a Ponzi scheme.
All right. What is a Ponzi scheme? A
Ponzi scheme is basically
the US dollar is valuable because people
want to use it. Do you understand? It
has no value in itself. It's only
valuable because people want to use it.
So now Nixon has to go and create demand
for the US dollar. Right? So the first
thing he does is he goes to Saudi Arabia
[clears throat]
and he creates something called a petro
dollar. [applause]
Right? The idea of the petro dollar is
very simple. Saudi Arabia which is the
largest oil exporter in the world will
only accept payment in US dollars.
Therefore if you want oil you have to
have US dollars. Okay? That's the first
thing that Nixon does. The second thing
that Dixon does is actually even more
important. What does he do? You guys
know he visits China. Okay.
Not only does he visit China, but he's
established a framework in which America
will give China everything. Okay. In
1980s, what happens? America gives China
its market access.
Right
now, US consumers can buy goods from
China. That's a huge deal, guys. Okay,
that's number one. Number two is America
gives China FDI
technology
education.
All right, imagine what happens. America
gives foreign investment to China, gives
all this capital to China, gives all
this technology to China, right? All
these military secrets that America has,
it gives to China for free.
And not only that, but America educates
the Chinese elite. Okay. 1980s, all
these Chinese students, Chinese students
for grad school, go to America to learn
America technology.
Okay. And the third thing, and this is
the most important, is
military protection.
All these conflicts that China has with
Southeast Asia, with Japan, Vietnam,
America will now protect China. When
Chinese ships export goods to Europe,
Africa, and United States, the US Navy
will now protect these ch Chinese ships.
Okay, you understand? You're like, "Oh
my god,
America gave China everything.
America made China rich. Why would
America do that?" And there's one answer
and only one answer. It's to make you
China use US dollars.
Okay,
it's that simple. Okay, so now when
China trades with the world, it gets US
dollars in return. You understand?
Okay, and the entire idea is to make the
world addicted to US dollars.
And now that the world is addicted to US
dollars, now that the world depends on
US dollars, America can now control the
global economy. Okay. So in 1999,
[clears throat] sorry, 1991,
the Soviet Union collapses.
Okay? And now America is the only game
in town. There's no one who can
challenge the supremacy of the
Americans. And so now what happens is
America creates something called the new
world order. The new world order is
based on global trade. But because
United States controls the US dollar, it
can now control something called
pricing.
Pricing just means that the Americans
can decide the value of everything.
Okay? So what America does is create a
price hierarchy.
So at the very bottom are resources.
Above that is manufacturing.
Then there's knowledge
and then finance.
Okay. This is the price hierarchy for
the world. All right. And it divides the
world into a division of labor. Okay. So
what is resources? Well guys, it's
Russia.
Okay, that doesn't make sense. Russia,
Africa, South America. What's made
factory?
China.
What's knowledge? Europe.
And what is finance? America.
Okay, does that make sense? So, what's
going to happen is that America is going
to take its manufacturing and transfer
to China. Okay? Because it's cheaper for
China to do it than for America to do
it. And all America is going to do is
finance.
Okay? What is finance? Finance is just
the creation of money
for the purpose of creating more money,
right? Okay. So, this is the system in
place and at first it sounds great
because everyone's making money. Okay.
But there are inherent instability in
this system. Okay? And we will discuss
all this instability throughout the
semester. But for the sake of
simplicity, uh let's talk about America.
What happens when you focus on finance
is that you become a speculative
economy. You focus on gambling. Okay,
basically gambling.
And this leads to something called the
2008 great financial crisis
when the
American economy collapsed. Okay. And at
this time the entire world economy
should have collapsed. And so what
happened was all these central banks
from around the world came together at
in Basil Switzerland the bank of
international settlements. Okay. Right.
The secretive body in which all economic
policies are made and they decide the
only way to save the world is if China
spends money. You understand? Why do we
have all these skyscrapers? Why are the
there all these airports? Why are all
these highspeed railways? Because
America because China to save the global
economy decided to invest in
infrastructure.
Okay.
And belit initiative and that saved the
global economy. Now after China did
this, [clears throat]
China developed a lot of debt. Okay? And
China basically said to the world,
listen,
um, we saved the global economy, so we
deserve a seat at the table, right? We
deserve to be equals to America. And so,
we're going to sell our products, our
Huawei phones around the world. Uh,
we're going to compete with America for
global dominance. And America said,
"Screw you." Okay? And that led, of
course, to Donald Trump. 2016, Donald
Trump.
And [snorts] the first thing Donald
Trump did, of course, was initiate the
USChina trade war, right? China wants to
be an equal to America. America says,
"Nope, screw you. We're going to destroy
you." Okay? So, America tried to
sanction China. Uh, America tried to
blockade China. Okay? So, we'll discuss
this again later on throughout the
semester. Okay? Then what happened of
course is 2022
Russia invades Ukraine. Okay? So what
Russia is saying is you know this price
hierarchy
screw this. Okay? Because guess what
happens guys? If you don't have any
resources this system doesn't work.
Okay? Try manufacturing manufacturing
without any resources. Try having
knowledge about resources. Try having
finance about resources. Okay? So when
Russia invades Ukraine, it's trying to
control the resources of Ukraine. Russia
and Ukraine together controls onethird
of the world's carbohydrates.
Africa, the Middle East starves to death
without Russian and Ukrainian grain.
Okay? Does that make sense? So now this
entire system is in jeopardy. Okay? And
so what's happening today is America is
fighting to save its game. It's trying
to fight to save the system. It's trying
to fight to save the US dollar. It's
trying to fight to save its hedge money.
Okay? And Russia and China are trying to
exert themselves. [snorts] So we are in
a time of game reset.
All right?
Game reset.
and that this is the world that we live
in today. Okay.
All right. So, we will discuss this
throughout the semester. Any questions?
Are you guys clear?
So, I I know this was a lot to take in,
but we'll go into just the specifics
throughout the semester. Okay. We'll go
we'll go and we'll we'll apply to
current events to explain why this is
happening. Any questions?
Okay.
So the only purpose of America like they
produce a service for China is to let
them use US dollars, right? So American
can use this game to everyone. But think
China does not do the same thing as
America. Like they created this this
game. Why?
Okay. [clears throat and cough]
All right. So,
um we'll discuss this throughout the
semester. Okay. The relationship between
China and uh the United States. So
remember that the United States wants
China to play this game, but they can't
really say to the world, "Oh, we're
doing this because we're greedy and we
want China to be subservient to us."
Okay? So they said that we we want China
to play the game because this game will
allow the middle class to rise. It will
make China much more democratic. Okay?
But that's that was just BS. That was
just a fraud, a lie, hypocrisy.
All right. So now that China is in this
game all right what it's trying to do is
restructure the game so that is more
more independent
okay because the problem for China is
okay
um
to play this game what you're doing is
you're taking resources right
you're um creating manufacturing exports
okay and so that's the role China in
this game. There's certain problems with
this game. The first problem is
um America controls the entire game,
right? So America can say, you know, we
don't like you, so you can't trade
anymore. So basically they stop
uh they limit the resources and they
limit the market access. Okay? So what
China needs to do to survive is idea of
diversify.
[snorts]
Create markets outside of the United
States. Create um like find resources
that are not dependent on the US. Okay.
So that's a game that China is playing
and that's the idea of bricks. Okay.
We'll discuss bricks later on.
All right. But the bricks is a very
different concept where before America
was trying to impose its game on
everyone. Now China is just trying to
create a system that is not so dominated
by the Americans.
Okay. That's a Chinese mentality,
right? Does that make sense? Okay. All
right. Any more questions, guys?
Okay. Great. So, I will we'll continue
this on Thursday. Okay.